What's the best heavy metal supplement?
Trying to think of a joke for that, but I better just plug my tongue.
So you're talking about detox in heavy metal, so you don't really want a heavy metal supplement.
But I'm sorry.
I have very much sense of humor.
But so I think it's to detox heavy metals.
I would go to the course, go to the seven phases of detox course.
So if you've worked through all the phases of detox and now you just want to key late out the heavy metals.
My favorite one is our phase zero key look clear.
Also the metal ex energy or the phase zero assist our phase zero six can be very good.
Hey, but practice all see is really good.
That's that's another thing.
And then there's milder key later.
So part of it has to do if you have still have a lot of metal filling to your mouth.
You can't use a heavier key later.
You can't use the one I first mentioned.
If you don't have any heavy metals in your mouth.
If you don't have any implanted metals in your body, then you could use some of those heavier things.
But it's all listed on the seven phases of detox course.